oh I think they are just as popular
today as they were back in the day right
it's crazy you know in st. get back
together but let's just ask Justin about
it that's gone Justin
good to see you congratulations on your
star on the Walk of Fame how does it
feel he said a lot of words it's
definitely at a loss for words but you
know who wasn't the fans that line to
Hollywood Boulevard
some of them slept out all week just to
be front row and of course et has been
with NSYNC since the very beginning and
this is when we first met NSYNC
don't be so waxy okay you guys get used
to this successes stardom
[Music]
get used to it
you just deal with it have fun you go to
a a meetings about these kind of things
it all started when Chris Kirkpatrick
didn't make the cut for the Backstreet
Boys and then came up with the idea to
start another boyband
Enter Justin Timberlake he and Chris
were friends then JT brought in his
Mickey Mouse Club co-star JC shows a
these two have done lots acting with
Mickey Mouse we act all day long
[Music]
next was Joey Fatone and Lance Bass was
the last to join after the original
fifth member a guy named Jason Galasso
quit we're living la vida loca our ears
are pretty crazy yes your madness look
at me hey see this is Justin from NSYNC
and you are behind the scenes of our new
video it's gonna be me
[Music]
this is our new incognito look you think
it work I think this gives new meaning
to plastic surgery for years it was all
about cool music videos crazy hair tweet
styles and amazing songs and sings told
more than 70 million albums the boys in
the band also got to witness firsthand
Justin's three-year romance with Britney
Spears our favorite matching denim
wearing couple broke up in 2002 that's
also when NSYNC went on a quote hiatus
man I'm tired of singing all of a sudden
you guys are all doing your individual
projects ones going into space you're
doing your thing is this mean the band
is thinking about doing the you know
taking a break I think that's what we're
doing right now you know everybody's
just kind of taking a little hiatus
doing you know other things that we
wanted to do
those other things well 4jt it meant
acting and doing four solo albums where
the others jealous it's really good I
mean there's a lot of stuff on there
that you know is so different and
especially compared to what we've done I
think his album is great and I think
he's a great artist the guys see the
talented man nope in fact jc1 soul as
well Chris did reality TV and had a
cameo in sharknado 3 Joey started My Big
Fat Greek Wedding
forget achillea and came in second on
Dancing with the Stars we're bringing
this battle to the dish we'll bring the
fun in the funk not smelly funky butt
dance [ __ ] didn't you do like some Star
Wars themed thing
lv.1 pitoni Lance did dancing too he has
his own radio show and became a role
model when he came out in 2006 Lance
married Michael Turchin in 2014
did your bandmates know your secret uh
no I mean I'm pretty sure the guys had a
clue
it's just nothing we ever talked about
myself
the guys reunited performing at the VMAs
in 2013 but as for life now JC is single
Chris and his wife Carly had their first
son Nash last October Joey is a father
of two and JT well he's all about
Jessica Biel and three-year-old Silas
but Justin's recently made these
confessions about Parenthood this is
really hard and I don't know what the
hell I'm doing I love you but I just
don't know if I like you it's gonna be
May
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]